tactical hide-and-seek private first
class sizzle whistle I think he's gonna
do a great job she's come out with your
hands up you might have heard of
hide-and-go-seek but this isn't your
three-year-old niece's birthday party
that's right today we're playing extreme
tactical hide-and-seek you guys ready
it's real simple the terrorists are
hiding the counter terrorists are
seeking terrorists job is to either kill
the counter terrorists or bonk him on
the head with a manifesto scroll then
that CT converts to becoming a terrorist
for the next round and it's up to his
comrades to save it this is gonna be
really hard because once you hide you
can't move you can only attack if the
CTS with him attacking range it's gonna
get dangerous in here strategy's simple
walk slow carry a big gun I hope I don't
get bonked by a manifest so it changes
my mind makes me to become a radical
that won't happen all about I'm trying
to get a spot where I can attack very
quickly lon - okay so let's do well know
they're here and I can get off for five
decoy six seven nine ten all right Ct
buddies you guys ready
Hey yeah you guys are great listen you
guys have your stuff on I'll probably
handle it but do you have stuff I'll be
ready when you're here okay here we go
whenever there's trouble we send in the
best
you could be anywhere especially on the
stairs
my back is totally exposed right there
did get attacked put up there under the
stairs man look over there
no terrace in there
that couch wasn't there before
I knew it three shots two more no they
didn't work as well as I was hoping it
would I'm thinking that both Jarrett and
Jake picked most obvious hiding spots
they could mm-hmm I'll show you the
crack in the door just to be safe he was
about to walk in the room to send in the
best yeah I wasn't even worried that was
just as I expected this no it's too easy
right now for the CT we need to make it
harder if Jarrod didn't constrain
himself in a barrel and you were
crouched down like this it has some
maneuverability you guys have been okay
Christian would have almost gotten me
next round would be better wants to tear
us learn from their mistakes do the
exact same thing again tactical Billy
tactical village terrorists are going
down I'm gonna make him smile I feel
like everyone just had a practice round
against Nico and I have to go in there
now against a more experienced
terrorists
how am I expected to win here all that
the Deeks
it might be someone behind the door the
moment you open it under this and
without even entering I'll open it and
I'll look through the crack
you should breach by kicking the door
open as hard as possible and letting it
swing and crush whoever's standing
behind it
swish you in yeah that's not bad that's
really good action yeah we're ready
hey Terrace
want some freedom no too bad do you
think anyone went upstairs is bright up
there why would anyone hide up there oh
gosh I couldn't really see through these
goggles in this darkness this is quite
freaky oh I don't want to have to go
into the tunnel of chains okay I just
like to turn on the lights
nope I don't want to go in there like
this hey I got some reconstituted
Constitution hey Jarrett come out did
really no-one hide
what are you doing are you hiding yeah
dude you're giving away my spot today's
episode guys
sponsored by raid Shadow Legends it's
this game right here I just downloaded
it a couple days ago and I've been
playing it since we have a lot of
downtime during this hide-and-seek game
I wanted to tell you a little bit about
this game it's one of the most ambitious
RPG mobile games out there that's right
it's got everything you might expect
from a brand-new RPG game I just
downloaded a few days ago it's got
amazing story it's got 3d graphics it's
got a bunch of different types of
champions you can play as the game's
good it's getting big fast try to get in
early they're doing a special launch
tournament upcoming here real soon and
it's gonna be giving out real-life
physical prize packs all you have to do
to download raid is click the link in
the description of this video right here
and you'll get 50,000 silver plus a free
epic champion right away as a courtesy
anyway I just wanted to let you guys
know except we're back here
freedom you are freed from life I am
running long time that was you you are
right here we didn't want to have to do
this but one of the C T's went down and
it's time to bring in one of the big
guns a super soldier the best of the
best is he a man is he at God or is he
hell on two feet well if you're a
terrorist he's all three
I'm the ultra special operator private
first class sizzle Wizzle I think he's
gonna do a great job feeling very good
about his loss of words for myself at a
loss of words for the energy that the
vibes I was getting it is up to you and
your nocturnal camera the hottest of
bodies need you get in there I'm just
you do work you understand yeah Mike
Roman Aidan's sis a Wizzle because I can
pick up down heat lines there's a little
see those you know those little wavy
heat lines that come on yeah that's like
a magnet
for me I spent 99% of my life in the
dark so I'm an expert on dark areas
reclaim the honor that our fallen heroes
have dropped on the battlefield I'm
going to totally forget it and figure
out exactly where they are no prisoners
someone caught me there's a bunch of
terrorists in here this is a Wizzle
that's the sound of my about camera
scanning yeah this is freaky bro
someone's got a hot speaker computer
monitors are pretty hot too hi this is
where [ __ ] gets real boys
empty come out with your hands up
[Music]
detected heat signature fading mission
success oh boy eating that you're
detected someone's behind the couch come
out with your hands up your sizzle lines
that comes straight off that body yeah
drop that manifesto and I'll and I'll
give you I'll bring you out live the
privatized health care system we'll take
care of him just fine two more
[Applause]
area secure one of us one of us one of
us I convinced you as my online essays
he got turned into a terrorist what
rather this is a Wizzle
that was good boy right there going in
there as the colonel over his direct
command yeah you're next in line yeah it
seems that way we know that you were
injured but you asked me to come out of
retirement we're asking you to come out
of retirement
God dang it how do you were you able to
do you I wouldn't do it for you I
wouldn't do it but for my country that's
a different story
give me a gun the only way to save him
is to bonk him back with this and then
he becomes Sam again that's only gonna
work on Sam yes everyone else gets this
or the knife can you put this can you
put it in my head yeah thanks and then
your knife you get a knife well that's
us well this part is clear but that's
the easy part
[Music]
that's a nice a nice round one
appreciate it
[Applause]
[Music]
got ahold fly-in the flytrap
that's one more terrorist oh the red
light is off
you got no lights now I feel like I'm
gonna do them again I think someone's in
there Sam you will this oh it's good
with you colonel feel it baby back in my
hands
Jared please just to put him out of his
misery okay okay it must be miserable
wherever he is and he's back here check
this room no heat signatures
[Music]
freakin geniuses another day saved well
I think everyone's seen what happens
when you use a thermal camera to play
hide and seek it gets pretty extreme and
I think it's a bloodbath all around but
I'm just glad that Sam and Clinton both
got out alive now if you're interested
in seeing some other games like this
leave a comment below or turn that
notification bell on because we do stuff
like this more often than you might
think as a bunch of grown men